[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
well Hank and Tessa am i right ladies I
was given one thing that I needed to do
on this podcast it was to say that line
correctly what did I say about scripted
content I am NOT good in it it's a
comedy podcast about death where two
brothers are sometimes one brother and
one friend answer your questions give
you to be this advice and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon that's a sports thing in case
they're new to the podcast
how you doing Tessa I'm doing so good
really enjoying Missoula Montana yeah it
is so beautiful here it's out of control
I completely understand why people want
to live here in the month of July right
this is this is one of the better of the
month yeah I it's not on fire yet and
it's also not made of ice yeah it's some
are May are two main seasons are Fire
and Ice here ice yeah next single well I
think that's the what the george RR
martin books in total are called a song
of fire and ice which is maybe it's just
about maybe it's about Missoula oh do
you not know about no idea it's the game
of Thrones book have heard of that yeah
I like the show I am cultured and so you
have been working for like a year on an
album maybe more than a year now yeah
bad ideas bad ideas I know where they
lead but I have too many to sleep mm-hm
lyric yeah yeah I've been working on
this album bad ideas what's the easiest
chart to chart on because I charted on
the Billboard comedy charts yes I feel
like that's probably one of the easier
ones I'm gonna say yes um I don't know
but I know that I don't qualify for any
of them because I'm like indie pop man
that's a fairly popular genre oh so
you're just not gonna get anywhere near
the top of that thing maybe what's that
what's on the top vote of confidence
what's what's on the top of indie pop
right now
I'm gonna think it let me try and see if
I can think of an indie pop song I don't
even know if that's a genre okay so
apparently indie pop is called
alternative oh because it's 1992 so say
Amen by panic at the Disco's number two
looking at an ad was a lot yes a lot of
advertisements um I don't I haven't
heard of any of these songs imagine
dragons best steel sir sly so these are
enormous
yes it's which maybe I'm gonna be by the
time this comes back half of the album
out yeah you know I didn't know that I
met Bex mom one time how was that she
was he's relevant to our questions we do
have a question about meeting famous
people's moms weirdly enough I was it
was backstage at a show that John and I
did and a friend of ours brought Beck's
mom along and she's like sort of famous
in her own right she was like a famous
mic person and sort of the air that the
Andy Warhol era yeah so it was cool to
hang out with Beck's mom and Neil
Gaiman's was also backstage of that show
no the test is like I don't care anymore
no but I was so starstruck by Neil
Gaiman that I basically was incapable of
doing anything that's funny
that was me like the first several times
I met you really yeah that's funny
really you didn't sense that no I'm
usually yes I'm bad at that interesting
because you talk about it a bit in your
book and I wouldn't get that sense from
you what do you mean well you talk a bit
about how there's a line where someone
approaches her on the streets of New
York about the idea of Fame it's strange
suddenly you don't know if someone's
talking to you because they recognize
your work or because they just think you
look oh yeah yeah and how someone on the
streets of New York started by telling a
personal story of her life and you were
like as the character the protagonist
april/may is like for the record not a
great way to start it because it was
confusing to me yeah are we do we know
each other well this is that
different though because I knew who you
were like we were colleagues yeah and
yeah so when when I meet people who are
big fans of but who already know who I
am I feel like I'm having a starstruck
moment but usually they don't notice
yeah because we have things to talk
about usually it's like what are you
doing at VidCon
Tessa do you want to answer some
questions from our listeners I would
love to not that I don't want to talk
more I just well we'll find some chances
to talk Michael this question comes from
Tasha it's the first question it says
dear Hank and Tessa the heat index in
Kentucky was recently a hundred and five
degrees unlike in cold weather where I
can bundle up I can only take off so
many layers of clothes without going to
jail
what are some of the ways that you beat
the horrible heat and humidity oh my god
I'm burning Tasha
hmm I just accept that I'm going to be
miserable and when I stop trying to
fight it I feel a lot more okay you know
this is true for me with food I have
sometimes like I can't eat for a little
while because of my intestinal issues
and I find it much easier to be hungry
when I know that I can't have food then
when I then when I'm just like sort of
being prevented by time and space from
acquiring food so that is a good a good
tip and I don't think that it work it's
gonna work a hundred percent of the time
I think that it once you climb up into
the hunt 130s he might be like well I'm
gonna die now yeah but but yes it is
good to sort of like find moments of
acceptance but I also wilt give it this
tip if you can submerge your feet in
water
my mom does that it helps so much yeah
it's shocking yeah I've actually never
done it it's I do it all the time when
it's super hot in Missoula I just like
sprained my feet off with a hose cool
fireman doesn't have AC so I'll probably
use that tip this week oh yeah you're
sleeping in no a/c land and he lives
upstairs yes all right it was fun today
I made a whole video about what to do
when it's too hot because I also used to
live in no air-conditioning land yeah
cuz in Montana it gets a hundred
hundred degrees like three times a year
but nobody has air-conditioning mm-hmm
but I do now think thank goodness but I
have a whole song it's called it's too
hot and it is a number of tips in it
about spraying yourself with water and
putting ice cubes in your pants and
making out with box fans and I was in a
viral video on Britain links channel
beat the heat oh yeah so some tips in
that yeah check out beat the heat or
it's too hot we've got viral videos all
for you honey 11 no no that was what
were the tips and beat the heat it was a
goofy thing so I don't want to spoil it
sorry oh man um I will say - I am very
rarely too hot so mine cold makes me
miserable I am too hot all the time and
I'm very rarely too cold
I love being chilly and I call it chilly
down to like 22 degrees yeah no I hate
being cold it gets cold when it gets
into the teens for me just like hit me
with another question - Ellie writes to
us
hello Shelley or Schiele possibly dear
Tessa and Hank I've been a barista for
two years and thus have heard many
estranged requests from customers
however the other day a woman asked if
our iced coffee is organic to which I
replied yes seeing us all our coffees in
the store is organic she then asked if
there's ice in it to which I replied
with yes because iced coffee is after
all iced she then proceeded to inform me
that by adding ice to the iced coffee
would make it not organic I'm still so
confused by this is ice not organic
probably not smelly Shelly Wow we know
that it's pronounced chilly that was
great it all worked or probably not
smelly Sealy um what's happening here
first of all we got to recognize that in
chemistry mm-hmm ice is not an organic
compound well water isn't organic is not
an organic compound because it doesn't
have it's not a carbon compound but
that's not what we're talking about when
we're talking about organic coffee we're
talking about the part that was grown
was it grown certified organic which
means the like no pesticides herbicides
or inorganic fertilizers I think and a
number like you know it's a
certification thing I don't know how it
works exactly was she making a prank
video
what was she making a prank video that
sounds like she's making a prank video
did did she look like can I couldn't
think about YouTube she was she does he
do pranks I don't know I feel like he
must yeah for the other thing you gotta
say is that like if ice makes it not
organic then definitely the water does
in the coffee because it comes from the
same place hmm can I just say this
person is absurd
yes is absurd Shelly / Ely you're not
crazy no unless unless it's prank video
in which case you should search search
YouTube video for organic ice prank and
see okay so that's a real that's a real
winner I think that it's getting tens
tens of views yeah Sarah asks dear Hank
and Tessa my can opener is in the
dishwasher and I need to open a can how
do I open it my spaghetti noodles are
getting cold and I need tomatoes to make
tomato sauce the storms are brewing in
my eyes Sarah I don't know what that's a
reference to I think it means she's
crying oh it's a Jefferson Starship song
about about Sarah what yeah Wow what man
that was a deep cut I like that Sarah
Sarah you can open your dishwasher and
take the can opener up that's sort of
what you got to do cuz your other your
other options are all like just hit it
with a rock or go get a new can opener
yeah or do you have a katana yes ooh
actually they don't call it a Cantona
for nothing
right that's that's the brand of katana
can openers yes actually this is a
pretty good idea yeah
it's not it's not terrible yeah could we
create a better can opener that's very
fast because it's a katana yes the
Cantona
yes the katana it's a little messy
that's all I've got there are there are
can openers various kinds of can openers
but I think that you only have one and
it's in your dishwasher and you know
where it is it seems like a fairly easy
what happens when you open the dish with
the dishwasher during the dishwasher
cycle the water immediately stops going
so just like open it just a teeny bit it
just snaps okay there's not like the
knives are not gonna fly out here you
you're gonna be just fine Sarah okay
but put those storms away get those
leeches out that's a reference to a
vlogbrothers video there you go
all right I got one okay Rachel or
Rachelle asks dear Tessa and Hank I seem
to be trapped in a moral dilemma I work
as a sales associate in a mall toy store
and at least once a shift I'm asked to
lie to a child oh well yeah that's yeah
that seems like it would obviously
happen cool parents will often bring
toys to the register only to hand them
to me saying something along the lines
of this isn't for sale right oh no these
types of comments generally come with
longing looks from both pairs this isn't
for sale this isn't for say it's a toy
store not only are you lying to the
child you are you're confusing them
about what stores are yeah it's like
it's not like the shelves yeah this this
isn't for sale right this is an awkward
spot to be in everything in the stores
obviously for sale it's a store for
goodness sakes she agrees with you but
I'm clearly being asked to lie to a
child in order to save the parents from
buying yet another toy mmm what should I
do about this do I play along with the
parent and send the child away
disappointed but the parent triumphant
or do I play dumb and hope that they buy
the toy in the end I do have sales goals
after all oh you have sales quotas mmm
feeling in moral peril for lying to
children Rachel well if you have sales
goals you gotta you gotta sell yeah I
was good until I heard that there were
sales goals which I didn't know was a
thing yeah
have you ever been in a situation where
there was a sales goal we didn't have
those at Walmart I worked at a clothing
retail store and we didn't it was
definitely good news for us in the
employees if we could make more last
month every month right
we weren't like we didn't get a bonus
and we weren't punished if we didn't
right okay so okay well assuming that
it's not like you're gonna be in a
problem spot or you're not getting like
weird toy commissions which i think is
seems immoral yeah I feel could you is
there a way to tell this story in a way
that's fun for everyone or or to say
like the child leaves the store thinking
I'm gonna get that toy later and if they
really do want it then they'll come back
and get it this is a trick that I use
where I like to leave a store or a
shopping experience between one thing a
thing and buying a thing me too I do
that too and everyone's like why don't
just get it if you want I'm like cuz I
want to know if I still want it yeah
okay from now yeah if I just want the
thrill of something new yeah so do that
to the child and be like oh no this is a
pre-release item it's only on the
shelves it's an advanced players copy
it's an advanced toy and then and then
say but like that will eventually be on
sale but right now you're getting a
sneak preview you are the first person
child to ever play with this toy we're
doing research but in an in another
month it will be out to the public yeah
uh or funny one might be like oh man ha
kid I wish you could have this but I
actually already got it it's mine I
bought it yeah I own about a third of
the stuff in the store yeah but there's
just mine I've bought it already yeah I
get paid a lot as a toy sales person
yeah mostly in toys yeah I I don't know
I mean if I were you in your position
realistically I probably just go with it
yeah because it's just the parent is in
charge yeah
thanks Rachel that's that's a bit of a
surprise but now that you've said it it
makes perfect sense to me and I'm sure
that in the course of the next eight
years or so I will I will probably use
this
trick on my own son yeah so thanks for
that as well I will be uh but why are
they in the toy store if they're not
there to get it I guess to get a cheaper
toy yeah I don't know that is don't take
a child in a toy store if you're not
going to buy him a toy that's tough
mm-hmm I went in a lot of toy stories as
a kid without getting a toy yeah yeah
but I understood we were poor so I was
like cool some time to play with stuff
right we're gonna go play with things
bit with all the very good toys yeah I
just live here now
yeah this next question comes from
Michaela who asks dear Hank and Tessa I
recently started a new job which I'm
very excited about after my interview I
discovered that one of the people who
interviewed me is the mother of a member
of a very popular and well-known band
which I will not name my husband and I
have been huge fans of this band for
several years I'm now working closely
with this lovely woman who has family
photos of her famous child all over her
desk space but who has never mentioned
the relationship I mean it'd be a little
weird to be like no dislike have I
mentioned all of my children to you I
don't know yeah does she mean never
mention the relationship isn't like hey
I have a son or and he plays he plays
the trombone and imagine dragons yeah
keep going keep going Sam okay when she
talks about her kids the fish just a
famous child is is quote the one who
plays drums sorry he doesn't play
trombone and imagine dragons how do I
bring up the fact that I know exactly
who her kid is and am a huge fan I don't
want to make it weird and I want to make
a good impression on my new co-workers
should i buy a coffee mug with the bands
logo and drink from it in front of her
every day until she notices starstruck
in Ohio Michaela no that'd be we don't
do that I'd be where that sounds like
the kind of thing that John and I would
suggest as a joke yes I do not do that
just get just get it like I love the
trombone and imagine dragons tattooed on
your bicep get his face tattooed on your
face face tattoo of her son's face
on your face it's subtle and ease your
point across I'll just like like walking
up to her with the mug and yeah I'm
having some tea would you like some tea
I saw some very real opinion on this
oh is that okay okay so I'll just all I
can say is I can speak from my own
experience oh you have this experience I
had a co-worker who had a son that was
in a boy band but they were not
successful ah yeah they had a poster of
like a wouldn't what happened was I
walked into his office and he had
several posters of like a bunch of young
attractive men in various states of
hotness and I was like okay this 55 year
old man really like this like weird
office young young men but then it
turned out that it was his son and that
was nice that it was explained to me yes
I like that yeah um well I guess I mean
I've been in the context of hat hmm
sometimes I get a sense that someone is
a fan of me but doesn't want to say it
because they don't want to make it weird
yeah but I guess it's not weird to me
that someone would be a fan I think
that's nice mm-hmm and sometimes that
weirdness right comes the weird part of
it cuz I sense that sometimes up but
there's no explanation for it I don't
know you don't want to be like are you a
fan cuz then that sounds really weird
yes yeah like I've done that before
where is somebody where I incorrectly
assumed that someone was a fan like what
and then and that's and I'm like oh if
you do it's like scishow or vlogbrothers
or what and they're like I have no idea
what you're talking about yeah that
doesn't feel good
no so I know that I like to if someone
is a fan to just kind of get out there
real quick yeah and it can just be
overact about them not yes their whole
identity right and also when I interact
with people who I'm a fan of the same
thing I just like to say it right away
because I know that I have an energy of
I'm nervous otherwise so I mean with her
I would say if it comes up naturally
like she mentions that her you know son
is playing you
like throw out naturally like that's
cool I actually love that man oh yeah
imagine dragons I love them I'm my
husband and I haven't listened to them
for years yeah but not like take me to
your house and feed me barbecue with
your famous son exactly just very casual
just like that cuz it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be weird well and
also like if this band is as popular and
well-known as you indicate which our
guess is that it is because I think we
figured it out just privately between us
that this woman knows that there are
lots of people who are fans absolutely
son's band and I can speak from my mom's
perspective my mom thinks it's really
sweet when people are like probably in a
little different way yeah but and that
gives her some I guess like it's true
that maybe if she knows that you are a
fan maybe there's some things that she
wouldn't say about you about her son to
you and maybe that's for the best
yes that's a great point yeah that it's
all it's a little bit dishonest to not
say yeah in some way but it doesn't have
to be a big thing treat it as a very
casual thing because it's it's totally
normal to be fans of music that's yes
which reminds me yes that one of our
sponsors for today's episode we should
just our sponsors now is the trombone
player from imagine dragons that
trombone player from imagine dragons
very under celebrated but also very he's
got a really great mom
lots of pictures of him on on her desk
somewhere sometimes they do the songs
under the advertisements imagine dragon
stuff
no just like podcast sauce playing the
show oh okay can I do one yeah this
podcast is we do some beatboxing for me
okay quiet beatboxing thank you this
podcast is also brought to you by lying
children lying to children children are
liars
you should lie to them too and also this
podcast is brought to you by the Cantona
the Cantona it's a katana for cans you
can open those cans late lickety-split
and get a little bit of tomatoes all
over you catch a this podcast is brought
to you by organic ice for 1 normalize
isn't easy enough we did good I mean the
the beatboxing is my favorite addition
that we've ever made to the podcast and
there's no way John's gonna let me do it
okay well for the record I disagree with
John that was awesome and you're
actually good at that you should do that
every time I'm just gonna take that clip
of you reviewing my beatbox and play it
over and over again to Katherine who is
not a big fan of me beatboxing cool you
can also hear Katherine arriving in the
garage right now if you listen closely
[Applause]
[Music]
anonymous writes ooh dear Tessa and Hank
I'm currently on a university summer
language program in Spain I'm trying to
learn Spanish and part of my program
requires me to stay in the home stay
with Spanish family I just arrived today
and my host mom is a lovely Spanish
grandma but I have a huge problem
firstly I'm really awkward with old
people I don't know what to say to them
I mean look this is legitimate because
you don't have a lot in common
yes like what a what do you're not gonna
talk about the trombonist from imagine
dragons absolutely not are the can't
Anna oh maybe that would she should get
her a candy Anna as a welcome mm-hm
yeah I mean if I'm being like I feel a
little dumb and then we're also gonna
just like let's let's summarize the rest
which is also that like anonymous is not
particularly good at Spanish yeah and so
you got to deal with that that barrier
as well so double weird and now you live
in this person's house and you don't
want to go outside because you don't
want to feel weird
oh no she says how do I avoid potential
awkward situations where we sit in
silence over meals because we just can't
communicate yeah I think that's that's
part of the whole problem of the
language barrier but also part of why
you're there
wait why are you doing a homestay so
that you can find little things to talk
about and and in those moments winning
you maybe are holed up in your in your
room be like okay what am I gonna say to
my excellent Spanish grandma am I gonna
say like these meatballs are very good
how do I say that how do I say how was
your day and then how do I say say that
in a different
way because I didn't understand any of
that yeah and then how do you what else
what else are you gonna say yeah like
like given try and like rehearse like a
report from home be like I talked to my
mom we discussed what's going on in
America right now with the whole like
ending of democracy and stuff sorry I
was trying to figure out what you would
talk about with your American mom yeah
and it sounds like will one it's it's
hard to learn a foreign language you
know that's an uncomfortable thing to
learn because it's hard not to be good
at things yeah you've probably sounds
like you haven't had a lot of
relationships with older people so of
course that's a new skill you're
learning too and maybe just have a
little grace for yourself but it's like
it's uncomfortable and that's okay right
like well it's funny to think about as a
skill but it totally is like huh like
knowing how to communicate with people
who are generally generationally
different from you yeah and then the
other thing I will say is the moment you
start learning a new skill you instantly
become the at that moment you are the
worst person in the world at that like
you go from being the person like like
most people who has never juggled to
being the worst juggler yes so you go
from being absolutely average just
another person who doesn't juggle yeah -
the worst juggler on earth yes and that
transition is unpleasant now that what I
will say is you very quickly go from
being the worst juggler on earth - what
like quite up quite a ways up the ranks
yeah just by sticking with it yeah in
the matter of an hour yeah and and that
is also true of Spanish yeah yeah you're
doing great don't be so hard on yourself
just treat it as an opportunity for you
to learn something new on both fronts
yeah and also but also like make that
awkward step and do it and have awkward
grandma hangouts that's a good advice
for that boom nailed it this next
question comes from Beckett who asks
dear Hank and Tessa
I found a Dodie video where she gets a
cello fixed and then decides she wants
to learn to play it after just one day
of having the cello she was able to put
together a video where she covers summer
loving from Greece I understand that she
has a musical background but as a person
who has been singing and playing
instruments for about 12 years I can't
imagine learning an instrument that fast
it starting to make me feel very
inferior it's like we're entering the
same question again a little bit as a
person who likes to learn new things and
does music why is it so easy for some
people to learn things why can't I learn
things that quickly also I agree with
John mustard is the best thing to put on
a ham sandwich and mayonnaise doesn't
belong on any food memento mori' Becca
well I don't know why I read that last
sentence mayonnaise doesn't belong on
any food you like man I love mayonnaise
in fact right now I like went reading
that I was like man I want a mayonnaise
sandwich right now a mayonnaise sandwich
that is just bread and mayonnaise first
of all that's not what I meant but it's
not like I've never done that
wow that is like a good like good white
bread with just mayonnaise on it
absolutely I think like a good good
thing to eat I'm not saying good for you
but I think that I enjoy its me feel
nauseated thinking about that
interesting yes a lot of people say that
about mayonnaise I don't get it I think
it's such a good it's like it's it's
like not liking butter to me oh no
butter rocks I know that's how I feel
when you say you know like mayonnaise
I'm like how could you not like butter
that's crazy
um I do like just a wee bit of
mayonnaise in my tuna salad well there's
it's literally what tuna salad is is
mostly mayonnaise I don't if it's mostly
managed it's bad tuna salad I don't guys
should just be a smallest amount I know
a person isn't me it's not the Katherine
I know many different people Jay King
who works for a company that sells
mayonnaise in bulk to supermarket
kitchens like the area where they make
the tuna salad that did all the various
things they're like what do they call it
with them with the marshmallows in it
marshmallow it's got a it's got a stupid
name Marsh s'mores mallow salad gross
there's such thing as marshmallow salad
yeah that was terrible I can't remember
the color panties and marshmallows yes
everything about this is heinous
what's the freaking call that's ambrosia
called ambrosia because somebody was
feeling it at the branding department
that day but I I have a friend who
south-south of mayonnaise to them and
they provide the recipes for like this
is very strange to me that the people
who sell the mayonnaise provide the
recipes for how to make the chicken
salad it seems like you shouldn't let
them do that because they obviously have
a vested interest in it yeah and having
a lot of mayonnaise in that yeah chicken
salad interesting and that I think is
why all grocery store salads are like 90
percent mayonnaise there so yeah they're
bad that Wow hmm are they are the
grocery stores required to use the
recipe no I don't think so
but maybe that would be good if you like
we'll give you the men as cheaper if you
use our exact recipes and we have and we
have copies of your surveillance footage
and we're watching you
cool speaking of surveillance what were
we talking about Dodie let's just pass
this question whatever I'm just kidding
okay well you know you know Dodie better
than I do you've been on tour with her I
do I know Dodie very well I haven't seen
the specific video um do we know for
sure that she learned the cello in one
day that doesn't surprise me here's what
I would say though we know that Dodie
can play this song on cello and doesn't
mean that she can play cello the other
thing is that like I know people are
super impressed with how quickly I
learned a guitar they're like wow you're
amazing you learned guitar so fast
you're gifted and I'm like well maybe
but I also spent like six hours a day
playing guitar yeah you can learn
anything pretty quick if you spend that
much time on it that is the thing that
is I think under appreciated about
people who are good at stuff is that
level of like you know in time
investment um and and I like when I was
learning to play guitar it was the same
way where I would play and I would like
do chord switches back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth
back and forth because there's no other
way to get good at switching between
cords because your fingers don't know
how to do that yet yeah so you have to
teach him how to do it and and now like
I haven't gotten any better at playing
the guitar in the last six years because
I very rarely spend any more than like
an hour at a time playing guitar yeah
yeah absolutely
and I I know that Dodie plays
instruments a lot like she spends a lot
of time doing rap so so I like yeah you
can sit down and like do it for six
hours and it's like the kind of thing
that only a youtuber like kind of only a
youtuber can do that so I'm making a
face right now you are i but what I mean
is like there isn't there is a it's
certainly not only a youtuber can do but
there is there's an advantage to doing
that when you are being compensated for
your content creation you know yes
you've got you've got people who are
watching and you you need to figure out
a good video to make you need to like
there's all these different incentives
to really dedicate that time but there's
also a great incentive to dedicating
time to mastery of anything which is
that it is a pleasant experience yeah
getting better at something is really
fun and good yeah
rocks and I want to learn how to play
bass guitar well hit those six hours a
day you'll do it well kind of I'm kind
of wondering if I can be competent
enough at bass guitar in the next month
and a half to play bass in September
because you want to play bass on you in
your band because you just do vocals now
I just do vocals now no man I play with
a drummer but on
Dodi's tour it's just gonna be me on
stage with tracks mm-hmm and I just
thought it'd be cool to play bass I
wonder if I can learn that before then
and I think honestly maybe I could we'll
see though oh man I want a mayonnaise
right now a great way to learn things is
to be super over-ambitious because if
you should like shoot for a really
absurd thing I mean you're at least
gonna get kind of good at it yeah yeah I
mean I also like when it's music I just
like finding a song that I'd like to
play what I love and then it's just fun
Abby asks dear Tessa and Hank some
nights when I'm hungry I'll be really
craving hot dogs then like ten minutes
later I think Chinese sounds really good
and
eight minutes after that I'm like dang
pizzas are yummy what do I do
once this happens I feel so conflicted
and like nothing I choose will satisfy
my needs I just well look foods please
help I'm starving not too shabby Abbi
I'm not too shabby I'll be this doesn't
sound out tough especially because you
could get all of these foods and then
just mix them together into a giant
casserole dish and bake it which sounds
really gross make me think of mayonnaise
do you not like mayonnaise this next
question comes from Jenna who asks dear
Hank and Tessa I really want to learn to
dance and they even have a police nearby
that has a relatively cheap drop in
class however I have so much social
anxiety every week I hate myself up and
get excited to go to classes however
when the time actually comes I think
about how much better everyone else will
be and I chickened out it's like we are
inserting the same question again I like
it but I have something new to say about
this okay I know I will never get better
if I don't go and I know other people
aren't even paying attention to anyone
but themselves but I still do get
nervous do you have any tricks for
starting to learn new skills or doing
things that make you anxious Jenna yes
Jenna here's one of my tricks I go into
something thinking about how smug I'm
gonna feel once I get good at it really
yeah and I just focus on that feeling of
how like I'm gonna bask in the fact that
I've learned something new and then I
know the only way to get there is to go
through the pain of being bad at
something and I let that feel me quite a
bit
think about how cool you're gonna think
I am if a month and a half from now I'm
playing bass guitar on stage so much
that's true right it's true and and
you're gonna be thinking Hank thinks I'm
so cool right now really so you're being
fueled by my future admiration I really
I'm very admiration driven not actually
something I'm proud of but there makes
me learn more skills yeah hmm you know
we've all got it we've all got to fuel
the tank somehow yep speaking of tank
filling your book is so good there's
just so many things that are relevant to
our lives I mean I did write the book
mostly for youtubers yeah that's great
it's so great Oh my turn I think so
Amanda men ass dear hand Contessa I
recently moved out of my family home and
while I did so for college a few years
ago this time feels different my mom was
really upset and although she's been
through this before at this time s'more
seems like more of a choice than a
necessity mm-hmm and the advice on how I
can cheer up please note that I already
pre-ordered her a copy of an absolutely
remarkable thing which comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order right now and it's amazing
people I'm reading it right now I'm
three-quarters through and I'm mad that
it's not out because I have no one to
talk about it with there's a mom here I
need he needs some some I don't know
adjustment it's I mean I completely like
as a parent you're you're gonna have
this sensation when your kid leaves
mm-hmm you know you probably like I'm
not saying like blanket statements but
and but like you can also have to be
happy for them and like the your mom
should not be putting this pressure on
you for you to feel like she is part of
the reason that she's sad like you're
the cause of her sin right yes and also
like to like have that sort of like
holding you to you know that like living
with your parents
yeah if you made a different choice I
wouldn't be sad right yeah I've never
been a parent so I can't well I've never
been a parent of a teenager so I also
don't know what this is like I'm sure
that or a twenty-something I'm sure that
this is difficult when the kid leaves
absolutely I know that it was but like
my mom was sad I think all parents are
sad when their kids leave but you know
like this isn't really on you yeah I
guess it's what I want to say Amanda
yeah but it is good to want to make your
parents happy as long as like that part
part of that is is like bringing you joy
so puppies cats hamsters yeah fish
bearded dragon not a bearded dragon oh
can I throw out there like I know I know
this is much easier said than understood
emotional
but it's okay for her to be sad I think
you can find us it's very difficult but
if you can't try and move into a space
where you are okay with her sadness and
it doesn't need to be your burden right
like or it can just be like yeah you
know without taking it on as something
that you're causing or you're doing
something wrong and if she's putting
that on you I'd say that sucks mm-hmm
because she should you know kids do
leave that's part of life yeah but and
that is a great point that like not all
negative emotion exists to be fixed yes
and sometimes like this is a sad time
and it's gonna be sad the thing that
made me concerned is when it was like
now my mom feels like I'm making a
choice and that's making her more sad
because it shouldn't be I'm sad because
you're making this choice you were doing
this thing to me it should be I'm sad
because you're leaving because like I
liked having you in the house because I
love you yeah I also read that actually
that's a really good point Hank so that
but I but yeah I think it's very
important in general in life not even
with just emotions like some problems
don't exist to be solved they exist to
be understood and appreciated and and to
like sort of say like I know that this
problem exists I know that this emotion
exists and that's all that's all we're
gonna do with that we're gonna continue
to live in the world having recognized
the existence of that yes excellent
all right one final question we're
hitting a lot of serious ones today @s I
hope you don't mind well I love I love
serious questions I talk about stuff
that's like I feel well I mean I've done
a lot of like emotional work in my life
and I've done a lot of therapy so I and
a lot of the things that I've learned I
wouldn't have learned if I didn't hear
someone else talk about it first in fact
one of my like journey to becoming the
better person was listening to a talk
show where someone related a relevant
problem to me and the host was like you
should read women who love too much and
like after I read that book I got into
therapy all that to say I do feel very
kind of good about talking about these
things so this has been great for me
well this final
chin comes from Molly who asks dear Hank
Contessa I'm 23 and my ex-boyfriend of
two years and I broke up more than three
months ago and I'm really struggling
with this whole friends thing he broke
up with me and initiated a conversation
about a month later which was fine I had
a conversation about boundaries with him
in terms of how much I talked to friends
and what it's okay to say because he was
talking to me everyday and was saying
just odd things so now we talk like once
a week not scheduled or anything and I
have never wanted our relationship back
in the slightest because it was
miserable but every time we talk I get
really preoccupied with just thinking
about us not in a longing way it's just
really distracting and annoying I want
to be the girl that can be friends with
her ex but why can't I be chill like him
do you think it's even possible to stay
long-term friends with someone you had a
serious relationship with can't think of
a sign off Molly that was such a sad
feeling jolly no yeah think of that one
sorry I'm leaning away from the
microphone cuz that's helpful um Molly
this is like a very legitimate thing and
when I read this I really hear you
struggling with feeling like if you are
honest about being sad or uncomfortable
with this that that somehow makes you
less chill or less cool less cool or
less mature maybe maybe you're feeling
like if I'm wrapped up in this then he's
the more mature one and I don't think
that's fair at all of a mature thing is
to be honest with yourself about how
you're feeling and it sounds like if
you're being honest you don't feel good
in this interaction and that's okay yeah
and I mean it sounds like you didn't
have a great productive relationship
with this person in the first place like
you say I don't want our relationship
back because it was miserable so and I
think that like like it sounds like this
communication is bringing you back to
that place it's not like it's not like
taking you forward out of it and that I
you know whenever anyone uses the word
misery
I want to feel like you should be moving
moving away from that place yeah and it
doesn't seem that there's that much
tying you together except the like the
the shared experience and that's not
nothing like you know they're there that
shared experience does matter and it is
it is a piece of your life that like
shouldn't be considered thrown away or
discarded in any way mm-hmm make it part
of its always going to be part of you
but I I know that it is possible because
I've heard people say that they've done
it to have long-term friendships with
people they had serious relationships
with I've never done it I've never done
it yeah I've never done it and I think
that's the norm and I do think that it
does exist I have a friend who has a
friendship with someone had a
relationship with but I think most
people are if I'm being Frank I think
most people are trying to convince
themselves they can be friends because
they think that's the mature more mature
thing to do when it's complete it
doesn't mean you think that he's bad or
anything it's okay to just say hey our
relationship is complex and I want my
life to not be complex yeah yeah and I
and also I'll commend you on having that
initial conversation with him in the
beginning which I know is can be a
difficult thing to do to say like we
need to talk about boundaries yeah
so I I can I can tell that you can do
this yeah you're doing great Molly
you're doing great Molly Tessa we're not
gonna have any news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon today no we're not they
stopped existing we recorded we recorded
this episode well in advance because we
needed one for them for the background
and test ilysm town so so I really
appreciate you hanging out and answering
questions with me it was a real good
time yes thank you for having me I love
answering questions but you should
listen to Tess's music yeah my songs are
available everywhere songs
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you're hearing
right now in the beginning of the
podcast is by the great gunnarolla and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
[Music]